gentlemen we have been bestowed with a
entirely new build of paper brand but Mr
Dan hulbert the Creator so I say we all
jump in and play some ideally about that
you wanna rob your play before right I
did like 45 minutes earlier yeah killed
ain't so good sounds all right what's in
classic versus yeah let's start with
classic Pam sofam for people who don't
know who's got the most experience on
this probably Chris hey what do you
think about killing each other in books
game about both killer i know is jan's
rip daniel john really good at this
stuff it's got the guys from monaco in
it which I appreciate so they've all got
like there's a halt there's a book theme
throughout and so like a lot of these
characters some of them come from The
Book of the Dead some of them are from
the book doodle paper I'm gonna go with
jasmine from the doodle paper nice I'm
sorry oh no it's too too close in color
I was me I'm calculating from DVD to DVD
and so bait you know you got your jump
you got your melee attack you got your
tap to switch gret your own personal
gravity yes and so you can and you know
like jump around and tap that a bunch
and just hover in the middle like my
hello guys I can read it yet look alive
I know I know there we go yeah yeah the
object is to jump around and / the crap
you murder each other Journey to the
Center of the Earth with Brendan Fraser
that's the video game all right who's
who I'm vvv green guy on the yoga dude
I'm really white I'm okay Horace I think
Oh get it get it boom we should mention
as well that and the creator of this
which is done whole Brazil nuts in the
game spot shot right now answering your
questions hey damn good job Dan which
makes it so we can just murder each
other here suck it all eight bombs mommy
look get cysts you also have two
projectiles every life you've got an ink
bomb ya got scissors the immune j'en AI
Chuck around this is Oh lookit from
downtown from downtown it's is lower
cool who's winning right now blue blue
09 nothing to see here it was definitely
winning let's get out when you win
seeing it when you win of a tear open
zone and
world and you have to exit through it
all he's got it he's got it stop them
from exiting no stop him from exiting i
guard it don't let your camping the
whole boys cuz because this is that it
gives us a chance what was that yeah you
heard me the first time no let me out
Knowles Arthur Oh son of a [ __ ] bloon
and jetty wins I was so close whopping
four I'm a ninja let's pick a different
arena in real life stop so this is a
skull kingdom what's Indiana down what
yeah there we go yeah yeah oh this is
way too breezy level in this is much
easier if all we did it get the double
check it out we didn't scissors oh yeah
pretty sure there's like a there's
climbs like a slams what I was trying to
save it yeah see there's someone a
friggin roll here everyone dies everyone
gets one on down everyone gets away any
i feel like i have a being vvvvv man i
have an advantage with this whole
gravity oh yeah because you're a veteran
of those gravity flowing oh no don't let
him have it mmm wait he's already know
he hasn't got it already someone has it
no the someone has tiny spawning and
Captain Viridian oh I don't know oh [ __ ]
don't matter damnit i win ah that's what
i was saying i didn't even know you
should have kept you stupid esta don't
let him have it you need to be more
specific more about green player is
winning murder green player the
meditation channel your golden eye and
screen sheet at the top left bottoms not
possible screen cheat when everyone's
looking at the same screen on purpose
and there's no divisions between it that
is the truth this one's a bit fine maybe
you should be more of a white around oh
you oh yeah maybe you should get myself
and Rob are just gonna kill each other
accidentally for the entire of this
stream I'm just gonna walk calmly around
the exterior I'll be honest Jesus
everybody these horseshoes really make
it hard to run a fly across the map yeah
killing people look alive i like it like
good ah yeah yeah yeah so i'm wondering
when he's morning when do you think
we're gonna go sick of catch competitive
games like this because I'm still not
know yeah never oh yeah yeah you can
deflect o arms as well right can you I
just tried I me not me and Chris had one
where we threw the bomb and it bounced
off each other I think did that happen
sounded alright sounds like sounds like
something that could have happened damn
you in a world Oh Nyjah oh you can't
deflate that justify kit yeah you did
which one's blue I am oh that problem
you just effect without baumbach amuture
I do that smiles yeah some blue ninja
Eddie the way over shh don't say
anything there's some closes crying
again all right let's back it up let's
suck it up so that's a pretty free for
all three for all FF a where we got
survival what's that is that like you
only X amount of lives probably survival
let's try that but see what happens I'm
gonna stick with ninjette e ninja jedi
oh wow don't upgraded on monk look at
that um look at me hold my bird without
the bird guy changing characters such as
low kerr i'm gonna be mumsy i'm gonna be
gentle men mumsy all that from Monaco
you left me remember to Monaco and the
video game Monaco they're making a new
game okay yeah pocketwatch games okay
realize are we doing the three this is
gonna get real maybe real quick real
layman out I'm gonna lame it out you got
a camp oh you deflected my body's oh why
did get diced don't fall Sona dick Oh
son of a dick oh never see our bullets
long trail yeah some mums no I just got
work who's there not an engine airway
and the mummy apparently the mummy the
one-eyed Cyclops mummy is this me and
water Scott ha come and get it mum's
chopping with those wings car mom's
coming again nope one on one baby let's
do us yeah
from a bird's writing like [ __ ] goris
damn it what a [ __ ] oh just hor ok
sounds like that at the beginning that's
fine that's ok it's gained cute names me
I like it my lord anything I was trying
to get you until you sit under the video
game oh love that oh we're playing oh
god don't murder me Oh who's using them
I don't know why we're ama I'm a hollow
did you deflect that come Oh squirting
is you son of a [ __ ] eat yeah I don't
know what happened but nin jetty when I
forgot we were playing Survival I'm not
gonna lie ok you know what you know what
more like for like 10 10 10 miss disco
11 yeah i know i was thinking one tear
oh yeah eat it a lot about survivors
killed myself with my head a chalk up
I'm a [ __ ] oh that scissors oh damn you
mumsy thank you look at this camper over
here yep strategic Oh something gallery
oh man oh oh yeah so this game is all is
currently on Steam greenlight so if
you're liking what you're seeing do down
a flavor and go wait around that saying
yeah do me a flavor giving something
nail I got sweet Pokemon too many people
over here Pokemon oh hi stranger my god
I hate that traitor yeah oh Jesus I'm
just taking names and I'm get my bomb Oh
midair bombings really good I do not do
that on purpose what's your I'm done Wow
get light blue he's got five or six oh
thanks for killing me Chris waters hey
man it's all makes you not a good scene
all right here who's blue Rob yeah every
runs do chris is yellow o gentle home oh
this is why we don't let Rob with ya
and I'm like that I didn't appreciate
that all right we got here we got some
team games here as well oh we're gone
team with the team's logo key left side
here look I trongsa couch first chair
left side strong sign remember the
titans we are on the left side from the
viewers perspective so yes we are the
strong side all right maybe it's oh
maybe we don't get to choose the left
side 20 oh you're talking about that
ageless today hitting a gotta get your
21 are you go right I don't know I'm
right ready top right wait how do we
okay Rob it's me and you all right Oh
detail all right let's destiny are
destined bros team picked the same dude
at least difficult to see different
colors for the sake of the weekend sorry
okay who did one pic I'll go taka oh
we're like literally pick the same guys
I went with the red or no if you can
burn squad I can't get it I'll just be
I'll be that guy just all right yeah
doesn't matter so you're blue and I'm
red yeah listen sure whatever it would
be super dumb if you could change that
check the same dude on the same team the
same code okay that would mean he would
not be able to tell who you were at all
I don't make video games Chris I only
complaint of it all right here we go I
don't know what this game is should we
do labyrinth obviously we're going into
the last corner Matt tens unit or Brian
you have to bring the animal squeals to
your base what what's good will oh oh
that thing yeah captured the quail
capture the flag is at home what Jake
will you want me scooch on over on a so
detective you gotta get the best dude
it'll do all right I think you better go
and oh you got it i'll plan D what I
have the quill you go I have the quill
well you don't you're the tiny blue dude
I am red look at me hovering on this
we're not on the same team okay who's on
my team I boil your blue as well yes
okay Kirk and iron alright me and Rob
bra get it done what a gentleman wow I
can't believe we been practiced figured
ya ass so long here we go we need to
kill like will dude I'll do it I'll kill
him oh yeah yeah if you can catch me
that ooh deflected oh wow I gotta get it
got it nice return nice for sharing it
we both did oh I didn't get it no I do
know i have i have it on it see not
sweet quill Robin school you see that
get that guy get that guy no I didn't
get a bad scene go go ahead go home come
at me come on me fatty oh oh [ __ ] fat
yeah sing it all right this is rad oh no
see if you have to have to judge it
there with all yeah go go go go go boom
you got to be my phone back I'm trying
[ __ ] that scene getting the hell away
yeah good work get get the plug oh ok I
believe in you rob float float I believe
in you rock wait we set the score dammit
attend yeah I'm say Oh see ya see maybe
this game mode needs like a timer not
just like bull crap you're getting away
to anyway scored man play first of 5000
you join ya commander come on in this
way hey bro come on and this blown up
here buddy oh oh come on again oh my um
get returned get bom bom get knifed
these points I just got it I gotta step
up my killing game can I just say I mean
the hair on this world is really kind of
like just kind of horrible what does it
remind you it reminds me of testicles
who's gonna come and say it Roz I need
you to get Rob back Robert my get
egoistic one's yours Rob Henry's they're
really i will throw scissors yes I'm
pro-gay chirps and he kept all right all
right you three first is we are one yeah
we told her one digas no stop no stop
five ruled yeah okay yeah that's
definitely want to change in your fate
we're probably running overtime but
let's just have another game because
it's good uh how do we do kill the king
that's a different mode yeah she capture
the coal was really well I was really
good to kill the cage brawl killer care
referral so Google Scholar get a kill
oops man you're the king and you're only
get points for King for Eagles lawyer
dude I'm my guys so top-heavy the head
is gonna like he's gonna fall over your
top have you look at my sweet dome am I
don't you live yeah I've got a hat I'm
the stumbling monk with the hat oh yeah
I'm gonna skull with big teeth what we
call that's what we've been telling
saying that about you for ages yeah all
rights call him 5 launch a video game
Donna this is a team game oh no it's
nothing he's the king now I'm the king
what was the quote again it's good
comedy king come at the King you best
out on this so I just can't wait to be
king oh that was nice or just kill the
king is the king I'm the king I'm V Navy
man hey do you need to get two kills
with games like it yeah I think I need
to get to I think the first you get one
too I know when you're the key oh yeah
yeah yeah 10 come the king and then you
get another oh no it's not a scissors no
it's time based it's the long read that
King the better oh oh yeah you just we
need a king just be a camper just get
knifed or scissored rather Oh scissors
me timbers let me tell her Oh ethereal
most like a sister or something hey
camping everyone's coming there's no
camping and this kid who's not possible
oh this red is doing a great your order
damn it son yeah I forgot what you guys
know yeah hey guys I'm over here hey
guys I'm over here damn it either Graham
over later look I pro oh god Oh gets
cues damn it come on turns out if you
just yell get cyst doesn't necessarily
ensure nobody can read gonna happen
don't you touch him yeah damn it nobody
touch below me sure deal
yep yeah yeah Tom it's cool i'm having a
hideous noise right there how did I not
goddammit paper bands and read steam
greenlight do us all a favor and just go
to that page and give it a thumbs up
with it out dude I was pretty good fun
yeah thanks very much @dan home before
starting to side with that bad boy yeah
I'm sure we're gonna make it an office
staple and we're back in a second that's
got paper fun Danny did I say office
staple yeah didn't by accident yes